nous
nick sont près de 5 millions après des
décennies de baisse régulière le nombre
de pauvres en france est reparti à la
hausse depuis 2002 chômeurs étudiants
familles monoparentales mais aussi
salariés plus personne ne semble épargné
pire encore des pans entiers de la
population jusqu'ici préservé se
retrouve fragilisée la pauvreté est elle
une fatalité
la solidarité est elle la seule solution
itinéraire bis vous emmène à lyon à la
rencontre de celles et ceux qui ont un
genou à terre et de ceux qui les aident
à poursuivre la route
dans cette émission nous irons à la
rencontre de benoît daniel frédéric et
perrine bénévoles ou salariés au secours
populaire de lyon
tous ont choisi de s'engager pour aider
les plus démunis aide alimentaire accès
au logement accompagnement scolaire
je vous emmènerai à leur côté pour
comprendre leur combat quotidien pour
endiguer la pauvreté
pas facile de bien manger quand le
porte-monnaie évident à bordeaux vous le
verrez la banque alimentaire offrent
bien plus que de la nourriture aux plus
fragiles denrées alimentaires conseil
pour des achats malins cours de cuisine
des bénévoles redonne du sel à davy qui
en manquent
et enfin des livres des tablettes des
ressources pédagogiques le tout sur
roulettes je vous emmènerai à calais
l'une des villes les plus pauvres de
france où on amène la culture là où elle
manque le plus au coeur des quartiers
des équipes de la médiathèque de la
ville ouvre les portes du savoir et de
la culture à tous
bonjour perrine bonjour joly merci de
nous accueillir ici à la fédération du
secours populaire du rhône ça fait plus
de dix ans que vous vous investissez
dans cette association
et ces dernières années vous fait un
constat sans appel la précarité s'étend
de plus en plus je pense qu'il ya deux
phénomènes
il ya déjà des personnes qui il ya
quelques années s'en sortait aujourd'hui
ne s'en sortent plus donc on est face à
des personnes qui sont donc ils
travaillent qu'ils ont un petit revenu
et qui aujourd'hui n'arrive plus à faire
face déjà à la réalité quotidienne
et puis on a aussi bien les personnes
qui viennent nous voir qu'ils sont dans
une dans une plus grande précarité qui
ont plus de mal à en sortir
on est en manque de solutions quand même
face à certaines situations quoi pour
comprendre votre quotidien on a passé
toute une journée avec vous et 24 heures
dans la vie du secours populaire à lyon
ça ressemble à ça
dernière mise en place avant l'ouverture
du magasin une boutique où toutes les
vendeuses sont bénévoles
ah bah voilà elle est encore un peu
d'élus des jeux pauvres mais bon à la
tête de l'équipe daniel volontaire au
secours populaire du rhône depuis 15 ans
ici on vend des vêtements mais surtout
on en donne aux plus démunis lyon est
une ville riche mais très inégalitaire
en 2015
la fréquentation de la permanence a
augmenté de 30 pour cent le chômage fait
que on a plus de jeunes qui viennent
dans nos permanences la situation des
retraités en france s'est
considérablement aggravée donc on n'a
plus de dossiers de retraités dans nos
permanences sans qui elle a deux
possibilités d'amélioration dans
l'avenir des publics auxquels viennent
s'ajouter de plus en plus de réfugiés
tout ce qui frappe à la porte du secours
populaire vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté moins de 1000 euros par mois et
beaucoup n'ont même aucune ressource
ce matin frédéric s'occupe du libre
service alimentaire se nourrir c'est
souvent la priorité de ceux qui viennent
à l'association ici on trouve une sorte
de petite épicerie ouverte deux matinées
par semaine pour faire ses courses des
points attribués en fonction des
ressources
25 en rhône alpes comme mounir à huit
cent mille personnes vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
à 47 ans elle élève seule ses deux
enfants 800 euros par mois pour payer le
loyer les factures et les études
alors elle a dû se résoudre à demander
de l'aide je suis en invalidité
j'aime bien sûr n'est pas très
importante donc je vous arrive à gérer à
gérer tous et pour boucler la boucle est
ainsi obligé de passer par là si vous ne
pouvez pas quand vous êtes confrontés la
détresse des autres ça vous atteint
quand même et puis en plus il faut
maintenir une une impartialité
rigoureuse donc on ne peut pas se
laisser emporter par un mélande
sympathique pour l'un ou pour l'autre
donc c'est lance pas facile un
engagement intense pourtant à tout juste
19 ans benoît a lui aussi choisi de
devenir bénévole au secours populaire
marie
en forme quand ils se sont emballées
étudiant en deuxième année de médecine
ils passent chaque semaine deux heures
chez jack pour l'aider à faire ses
devoirs à 12 ans le jeune garçon en
classe de 6e à de grosses lacunes en
orthographe
marie a eu peur et s'est caché
l'objectif pour moi c'est que déjà que
jake se sentent bien à l'école et que il
arrive à faire ce qui ce qui veut plus
tard je crois beaucoup au fait que les
versions se fait aider on peut arriver à
la même chose que n'importe qui et qu'on
a les mêmes chances dans la vie et du
coup c'était important pénale une aide
précieuse pour les parents de jack qui
n'ont pas le temps ni le bagage
nécessaire pour aider leur fils moi je
travaille tôt le matin puis un certain
le soir ma femme est bien là comment
dire il ya des choses qui la dépasse un
petit peu par rapport à certains
exercices
donc voilà donc le fait d'avoir des
étudiants qui viennent nous aider c'est
mais quel con on a vraiment vu comment
dire une amélioration jack et ses soeurs
ont aussi eu la chance de profiter de
quelques jours de vacances grâce au
secours populaire
les vacances c'est l'engagement
historique de l'association retour à la
permanence aujourd'hui encore 40% des
français ne partent jamais alors ici on
aide les familles à organiser des
séjours à bas coûts j'ai trouvé aux
dates où vous vouliez quelque chose en
pension complète qui on va regarder qui
vous revient très peu cher mais c'est en
alsace partir une semaine en vacances ça
permet de sortir du quotidien et du coup
du quotidien difficile et ça permet
d'avoir une bouffée d'oxygène dans dans
ces temps là
des bénévoles qui parlent tous d'un
monde qui marche sur la tête
mais qui continue à actionner chacun de
ces leviers pour entretenir l'espoir
d'un monde meilleur
on se retrouve avec sébastien tholot le
secrétaire général de la fédération du
secours populaire du rhône et mounira
bénéficiaires de l'association on se
trouve là dans les entrepôts de la
fédération sébastien on vient de le voir
dans le reportage le secours populaire
du rhône doit faire face quotidiennement
à une situation qui se dégrade de plus
en plus
oui c'est un constat qu'on fait
malheureusement depuis de nombreuses
années donc la fédération du rhône
regroupe 23 comités locaux et cette
initiation qu'on retrouve aussi bien
dans lyon que dans les villes
environnantes
on a eu une augmentation des demandes et
de personnes qui arrivaient à s'en
sortir qui peut être s'en sortent et
difficilement mais qui arrivait à s'en
sortir et quand on est sur le fil du
rasoir tout le temps à un moment donné
on bascule
il a la grande difficulté c'est qu'on
peut basculer très vite vous maniez rats
comment vous avez frappé à la porte du
secours populaire
en fait moi j'ai un soucis de santé
importants et donc depuis 2004 je suis
en invalidité sans pouvoir reprendre le
travail mais la mi temps thérapeutique
donc j'ai une fois son habilité sur un
mi temps et comme j'avais mes jumeaux
sol depuis qu'ils ont de moi mais bon ça
a été ça a été compliqué c'est difficile
de faire cette démarche de venir
demander de l'aide
départ sa part n'a pas été facile de
franchir le pas parce que ben mes parts
on n'ose pas on n'ose pas trop et puis
on dit qu'à des gens ont compris ce
besoin que que nous donc on est bien et
leurs membres
on est obligé d'y aller parce qu'on en a
plus on a plus on n'a plus de quoi faire
manger les enfants on a plus que la main
on saute le pas est ce que la pauvreté
s'est banalisée ces dernières
je pense qu'on s'habitue voir autour de
nous la pauvreté sous toutes ses formes
et quand on s'habitue ça devient
compliqué parce qu'on admet on en admet
cette attaque fait notamment pour les
autres et ça c'est quelque chose qui
équipe pour moi mais aussi pour
l'association reste doit rester un
clignotant et puis en ayant ce discours
ambiant on certaines personnes qui sont
dans la précarité ou dans la pauvreté se
dise pas oui effectivement c'est comme
ça et pour moi c'est comme ça et ça
restera comme ça on n'y a pas de raison
quand on n'a pas les moyens au quotidien
on se prive parfois de certaines choses
plus on sait que j'arrive à un stade où
je mens 3 plus d'aller boire un café ou
voilà je suis tous ces choses là quoi
j'ai plus qu'on perd le goût l'envié le
goût quand on fait tout simplement noir
moi je suis quelqu'un qui ne bougeait
beaucoup qu'ils aient plein de choses
qui à vrai que c'est pas venir à vous
pensez encore que la société peut se
transformer
commence alors pour moi les empreintes
du craf lui donc
mais bon j'ai l'âge par la chance
d'avoir un caractère de cochon et de me
battre à tous les jours de me dire il
faut il faut il faut il faut
et moi je vais des mamans autour de moi
mais on finit un hôpital en dépression
laissant des enfants des enfants un
petit il ya des choses plus graves quoi
dans la démarche du secours populaire il
ya la volonté de pas uniquement aider
les gens mais également de leur donner
les outils pour qu'ils deviennent
acteurs eux-mêmes pour qu'il s'en sorte
un c'est important ça pour vous surtout
ne pas être dans l'assistanat
l'assistanat ne règle rien venir dans
l'association s'est aussi essayé de de
mieux prendre en main sa situation
quand on voit comment des personnes sont
venues un moment donné demander de
l'aide et reviennent nous voir sans
demander quelque chose mais juste pour
venir voir des personnes qui les ont
aidés et aussi des personnes qui
hésitent à un moment donné voilà j'ai
été aidé ou je peux aussi aider et c'est
aussi très important
merci sébastien merci merci difficile de
bien manger quand on a un budget serré
en france près de 4 millions de
personnes bénéficient de l'aide
alimentaire à bordeaux la banque
alimentaire apprend aux plus précaires à
acheter malin éviter le gaspillage ou
concocter des plats équilibrés des trucs
et astuces pour retrouver du plaisir
sans débourser un euro de trop c'est un
rituel chaque jour six camions de la
banque alimentaire parts aux aurores
encore vides ils vont faire le plein de
produits frais directement au pied des
grandes surfaces depuis février 2016
les enseignes de la grande distribution
n'ont plus le droit de jeter de la
nourriture encore consommables une
aubaine pour la banque alimentaire de
bordeaux qui récupère 5000 tonnes de
denrées chaque année qui si elle vire
quatre sites rome une a3 qui sent bon et
tmc moisi mais les trois sont bons ça
veut dire que dalle dans l'esprit qu'on
va avoir un peu plus tard il ya des
personnes mais titré sur les trois
citron citron banger des trois lots pour
partir à la poubelle tout est stocké ici
dans ce hangar pêle-mêle salades
carottes et même des navets boule d'or
attente d'être donnés à des associations
partenaires
mais aujourd'hui nicole marie natali est
thomas des personnes en situation de
précarité sont venus faire leur marché
et réapprendre à cuisiner sans se ruiner
ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui on
l'atelier en fait c'est de faire un
petit tour et de regarder ce qu'il y à
haut niveau de l'entrepôt en termes de
légumes de ce côté de fruits on ira voir
dans le frigo la viande si la viande de
poisson il ya beaucoup de gens qui
aiment qui finalement
g c'est plus un plaisir ça reste de la
survie donc ils vont manger
j'ai simplement pour se nourrir donc ils
peuvent ouvrir une boîte manger une
boîte
enfin voilà donc ces ils vont aller vers
l'essentiel est souvent sont des plats
tout préparés ils prennent plus ce
temps-là apprendre à cuisiner ça
commence par bien faire ses courses pour
éviter les tentations et petites astuces
quand on va faire ses courses
ça peut être notamment ne pas y aller
quand on a faim donc bien manger voilà
toujours parce que sinon on aurait
tendance à vendre voilà t'y pas
n'importe quoi donc prendre une liste
voilà elle respecté ce qu'on a mis sur
la liste voilà à bourges avait pas dit
je faisais d'abord le tour des
promotions en fait je claquais trois
fois le budget je m'essaie odeyer tôt un
petit gâteau ce site n'est privilégié
les produits pour huit cantons peu mais
pour céline monteuse 1 il y encore plus
économe
je leur explique que au niveau de leurs
courses ça peut être intéressant
d'acheter des légumes surgelés parce que
au niveau rapport qualité prix il n'y a
pas de perte
quand on achète un kilo de poireaux au
frais l'autre poireau surgelés dans les
poires offrait finalement on va en
perdre la moitié alors que le kilo
surgelés on va le manger entièrement
maintenant place à la pratique
pour moi on se répartit nicole tu es
parti sur les champignons oui elle n'a
pas de toc
mais c'est elle la chef céline monteuse
1 re donne les bons réflexes pour
cuisiner les aliments sélectionné donc
le meilleur c'est bien sûr c'est la tête
donc avec l'économe tu vois là où c'est
tout flétri hop tu casses comme ça et
après tu vas et on va les mettre au cul
vapeur et bien allez vous pouvez
attaquer au menu aujourd'hui asperges
vinaigrette poêlée de champignons et
saumon et poires pochées un repas
gastronomique pour moins de 3 euros
pour beaucoup les gens cuisinent pas
spécialement on s'est souvent dans les
minima sociaux c'est souvent la même
chose un patrie à partir du vin du moins
ses pâtes au riz pâtes au riz pâtes au
mi6 on peut là vraiment et avec quelque
chose tous voient rien la buse ou lyon
la consigne aux inégalités parce qu'on
n'a pas tous les mêmes bases on n'a pas
tous des parents qui ont verrière
vous apprennent à cuisiner des endives
moi ça fait partie de notre quotidien il
ya des gens qui ont découvert les on dit
voilà dans l'atelier enfin des blettes
des salsifis fait pour les gens c'est
leur donner accès aux connaissances
qu'ils n'ont pas eue
voilà donc dans leur vie passée se faire
plaisir et dépenser juste ce qu'il faut
céline a même des petits secrets pour
jeter le moins possible comme les
épluchures de pommes de terre qui feront
de savoureuses chips au final une table
dressée digne d'une bonne brasserie un
menu pas cher malgré la qualité des
aliments
de quoi ravir le porte monnaie et les
papilles gustatives
avec ap jean bonjour vous êtes la
directrice de la mairie la mission
régionale d'information sur l'exclusion
une association qui soutient la lutte
contre la pauvreté ici en rhône alpes
on vient de le voir dans le reportage la
banque alimentaire à bordeaux qui
offrent de la nourriture aux plus
démunis mais également des ateliers de
cuisine
aujourd'hui en france trois repas par
jour c'est un luxe pour beaucoup de
monde ah ben oui c'est un luxe à deux
niveaux c'est un luxe de manger trois
fois dans la journée mais c'est aussi un
luxe de manger correctement trois fois
dans la journée
être pauvre aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
être toujours obligé d'arbitrer entre
des besoins fondamentaux
donc les gens en fait ils doivent
choisir entre manger ou
boire un café à la terrasse
d'un troquet et il ya plein de gens qui
nous disent ben moi une fois par semaine
je préfère pas manger et voilà prendre
mon café au milieu des gens de la vie et
donc voilà ils font des choix comme ça
et souvent c'est l'alimentation les deux
les deux choses qui passe très souvent à
la trappe c'est l'alimentation et la
santé ça veut dire quoi aujourd'hui être
pauvres en france alors en france et
plus globalement en europe il ya un
seuil de pauvreté qui est défini à 60%
du revenu médian donc pour une personne
seule
tous ceux qui sont en dessous de 1000
euros ils sont considérés comme pauvres
pour une pour un couple c'est autour de
1500 euros et pour une famille avec deux
enfants c'est au tour de 2200 euros
après des décennies de baisse régulière
le nombre de pauvres en france est
reparti à la hausse
la faute à la crise autant il n'y a pas
forcément plus de pauvres
mais alors ce que la crise a produit
c'est que ceux qui sont pauvres s'ils
sont pas plus nombreux ils sont beaucoup
plus pauvres et ils sont de plus en plus
pauvres
ce qu'on pressent quand même c'est que
aujourd'hui si on veut
lutter contre la pauvreté il faut poser
la question des inégalités où on pourra
pas lutter contre la pauvreté en
développement en développement des
politiques publiques spécifiques et des
droits spécifiques pour les personnes
qui vivaient les situations de précarité
on est pourtant dans un pays où on
redistribue beaucoup d'argent est ce que
le système fonctionne mal je sais pas si
on peut dire que le système fonctionne
mal parce que de fait et nous voulons le
voit un les personnes malgré des
situations de pauvreté
on a quand même construit de sécurité
manuel valls vient d'annoncer une
réforme des minima sociaux
d'abord pour les simplifier mais aussi
pour les rendre plus accessibles aux
jeunes c'est une bonne idée alors les
rendre plus accessibles oui rendre aussi
le
le fonctionnement plus lisible pour les
personnes et du coup qui facilite
l'accès aux droits des gens ça oui après
moi je me pose énormément de questions
mais à titre personnel et en fonction de
ce qu'on voit par rapport à un rsa
jeunes autant la question des ressources
financières de ces jeunes là c'est sûr
que c'est une vraie question
autant leur dire voilà mon petit on va
te filer le rsa moi je suis pas sûr que
je suis pas sûr que même
en terme de projet de société ça soit
l'ambition dont on a besoin pour nos
jeunes quoi l'état d'un côté les
français de l'autre qui donne beaucoup
mais quand on regarde de plus près on
s'aperçoit que ce qui donne aux plus
fragiles ce sont les pauvres eux mêmes
ça peut paraître surprenant mais
pourtant c'est massivement vrai les
premiers pourvoyeurs d'aidé alimentaire
c'est pas la banque alimentaire spa les
restos du coeur c'est les proches des
personnes en situation de pauvreté qui
sont soit elle même en situation de
précarité soit dans des situations
sociales très modeste je sais pas si qui
est de plus ce qui est de le moins mais
ce que je sais c'est que les personnes
qui vivent en situation de précarité
elles participent massivement à la
solidarité nationale
et que de manière très peu visible voilà
on valorise beaucoup ce qu'elle reçoive
on valorise très peu
ce qu'elle donne merci annaïck merci à
vous donner c'est utile mais donner un
accès au savoir 7 offrir aux personnes
les plus éloignées de la culture des
pistes pour s'en sortir
calais l'une des villes les plus pauvres
de france vient d'investir dans une
médiathèque itinérante des livres des
tablettes et des ressources pédagogiques
sur roulettes balader de quartier en
quartier pour faire reculer l'ignorance
la médiathèque de calais 180 me
documents à la disposition de tous un
lieu ouvert et gratuit
andrea aime bien farfouiller à travers
ses rayons à 20 ans elle a déjà connu
beaucoup de galères le chômage est aussi
la rue passé le conte préféré coin bd
manga tout ça une bd c'est on va dire
une quinzaine d'euros et une quinzaine
de robin c'est peut-être pas les courses
pour une semaine mais presque cinéma
livres musée avec 330 euros par mois la
culture est aussi un luxe qui reste
essentiel à ses yeux sans culture pour
moi on peut pas vivre dans le sens où
ben quand on sait des choses on peut en
parler on peut les partager
et plus on enrichit ses connaissances
plus on enrichit on va dire notre
bibliothèque personnelle culturel main
plus on s'ouvre aux autres à calais 25 %
de la population vit en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
et même dans une ville moyenne comme
celle ci certains quartiers restent
éloignés de l'accès au savoir
pour y remédier la ville expérimente
depuis six mois une solution pour le
moins originale
ils ont bien des terrains de sport
commence un étrange ballet à l'intérieur
de ces mâles orange verte jaune d'une
médiathèque se déploie en quelques
minutes une installation comme celle là
ça prend 20 minutes à 4 c tous les
modules sont déployés les jeux sont
installées les documents sont rangés
c'est assez simple d'utilisation c'est
plutôt pratique n'a tout tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour recréer une bibliothèque
éphémère pendant un moment donné dans un
dans un quartier dans un centre social
dans une salle de sport tous des
endroits aussi insolites les uns que les
autres ils vont enlever les manteaux ou
enlever les manteaux des lieux insolites
pour amener la culture là où elles
manquent au plus près des habitants dans
ces quartiers populaires ou pousser la
porte d'une bibliothèque ne va pas de
soi mais ça change tout parce que en
fait mais les gens nous perçoivent
autrement il ya une voie dans une
posture différente
il voit ce que la médiathèque peut
proposer le lieu
un lieu qu'ils connaissent déjà puisque
c'est un lieu qui fréquentent pour des
activités sportives autres donc ce lieu
le connaissent déjà
ils le découvrent d'une autre manière et
nous découvrons d'une autre manière ils
se lisent dans la médiathèque ça peut
aussi être pour moi parce que c'est ça
souvent encore on remarque qu'ils encore
des personnes qui ont une certaine
appréhension
tu recommences allez on y va abb loup a
perdu son doudou
oh bah oui dont heureusement i do quelle
drôle d'idée une médiathèque itinérant
pour amener les gens à la culture mais
pas seulement on les accompagne sur
l'autonomie documentaire comment trouver
une information comment comment se
débrouiller dans la vie quand on
recherche un emploi ou quand on veut
faire une formation un lieu de vie des
changes mais aussi d'apprentissage tu
vas pouvoir lui changer son costume
ça veut dire tu vas pouvoir les changer
sa couleur avec cet atelier des enfants
sont apprendre à programmer un jeu vidéo
en fait c'est un arrière plan avec des
pilules temps ça leur apprend la logique
non voit aussi la créativité avec les
dessins ça peut être également aussi la
programmation
la logique quand on voit vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
initialement développé pour des camps de
réfugiés
cette médiathèque sur roulettes faut-il
s'en réjouir a trouvé toute son utilité
en france
voilà itinéraire bis touche à sa fin
perrine on vient de le voir dans ce
reportage
à l'instant cette médiathèque itinérante
qui donne un accès à la culture aux plus
précaires
la culture elle a un vrai rôle à jouer
dans la lutte contre la pauvreté
oui à mon avis la culture c'est un vrai
levier contre l'exclusion en fait les
personnes qu'on accompagne qui sont dans
une situation de pauvreté de précarité
se sentent un peu exclu aussi de cette
de la culture du théâtre du musée du
cinéma et de pouvoir leur permettre
l'accès salir valorise aussi ça leur
permet de s'épanouir de passer des
moments loin de leurs soucis quotidiens
merci perrine un de nous avoir ouvert
les portes du secours populaire de lyon
je vous en prie on l'a vu dans cette
émission la france a beau être l'un des
pays les plus riches au monde
la misère ne cesse de progresser un
constat alarmant qui doit nous
interroger sur le fonctionnement de
notre société
à bientôt